now we will hear from wilson palacios
who is actually from the university of
south florida as an associate professor
but he is here
doing some work with sierra as well
he's going to talk about the conference
attendance
attendee survey that many of you
completed wilson thank you
good morning everyone
and as leaf said
i'm here doing some work with sierra and
over the next two years and
hopefully uh
over at that time maybe some work with
some of you in the room on this very on
this effort
the purpose of this short 11 item
anonymous online survey that many of you
participated in was to provide you a
mechanism for informing us of your
current
of your current and future efforts and
needs in the areas of hiv prevention and
intervention services
as you see we have a we have a total of
190 registered attendees of which 133
completed the online survey
going by question by question in terms
of the role that you play in hiv
prevention the message here is clearly
that we have a wide array of
professionals in the field represented
here today
what's most notable is the other
categories you see which about is which
is at 34
in opening up this category and
revealing the qualitative data i was
pleasantly surprised to see that
here too we had a wide range array of
professionals
most notably professionals from the
areas of
the medical community
medical case managers grant writers
researchers etc
in terms of services that your agency
organization provides
the message here is clearly that we have
eight representatives from hiv
prevention services followed by hiv care
and support services
again the other category as you can see
reveals even more interesting
information
in terms of
services agency is providing we have
partner
partner services std prevention
in outpatient services and medical case
management
in terms of specific hiv prevention
services
the message clearly here is counseling
testing and referral
followed by comprehensive risk
assessment counseling services and once
again in opening up this other category
i was pleasantly surprised to see that
the message here was focusing on partner
services primary care to children and
peer non-peer uh outreach
in terms of particular capacity uh here
the message clearly is hiv positive ms
followed by msm
i idu or people who inject drugs
and high risk heterosexuals
the other categories revealing college
students incarcerated and
formerly incarcerated populations
in terms of level of
experience
clearly you see here that among those
that participate in the survey the
experience is is vast
in terms of agency planning
um
the message here is whether you you
intend to provide hiv services in the
future
again here the message is one of of
commitment
in terms of training
we clearly here see that the message is
one on outreach specific interventions
general msm information
and over 30 percent indicated uh
need of training in
techniques of community mapping and
assessment
uh opening up the other category we saw
uh individuals here indicating a need in
training for focus groups and basically
writing those research grants to help
you get those dollars to continue your
work to the next level
in terms of
capacity building the message clearly
here is on staff development
new program development and
building
collaboration okay
under the other category here i was
pleasantly pleasantly surprised to see
that many of you indicated again funding
community based sites to pilot and
evaluate innovative educational
platforms for msm populations
and clearly here in terms of in the
field of hiv prevention how much of a
priority is hiv prevention for msms
clearly you see here the message once
again is on commitment so a lot of
positive messages themes coming from the
online survey that many of you
participated in
in terms of the pop quiz here as you can
see okay
in terms of the true versus who you know
true versus false i would say that the
message clearly here is
that your knowledge in the field your
practical experience the day-to-day
activities that you engage with and
serving
across the board many different types of
populations translates into a very
strong knowledge base i think you know
with today's theme for today's
conference
the challenges is taking the next step
forward and hopefully in a collaborative
effort
thank you